what was the movie you were on where it
was kind of like a boys club
I think Clooney was directing you Marino
Clooney and I forget who else was in
that but it was like a whole day and you
kind of stayed in your trailer did entry
you didn't want to really mess up their
social thing right yeah I tried to hang
with them but you know Matt and George
would always have these conversations
and you know they go out for cocktails
afterwards and I don't really drink and
I don't bring a lot to that party
because they're you know super a level
guys but Bill they gave us bicycles
right George George bought everybody
bicycles right buy bikes with Bill Bill
Murray yeah he's something right you
love this guy oh I adore am I just a
force of nature why is he so great let's
say you're riding a bike with him what
happens that's so great I just go get
lost and they they had to send guys and
cars out to look for us and you'll and
to make sure like you know Bill's not
gonna go over any borders or cause any
trouble because Bill's one of those guys
that is completely uninhibited he will
go up to perfect strangers invite
himself to their party and go to their
house he would he would we were in a
small town in England and women would
approach him so bill would pick them up
and put them over his shoulder you're
saying Bill Murray has that special gift
of people like my department he's always
been like that and he's you know he's
worked it to the point where there's
there's one of a kind or they broke the
mold whatever the cliche is he's just
unique do you wish you were more like I
sure do you do because well I wish I had
that that sense of place that he has it
he knows who he is and he's very
comfortable in his skin and he's but
he's also brilliant when did you meet
him out on Saturday night I met him at
the 25th Saturday Night Live reunion
yeah I met him in New Orleans one time
at Tipitina's we were watching the
Neville Brothers and I
I just felt free to walk up to him when
he was gracious and what happens then
then it's kismet and you guys hang out
for an entire evening oh we didn't we
didn't hang out I left him I left him
alone you did yeah he doesn't need some
hanging around with him why do you refer
to yourself as as famille I mean you're
a famous guy you're an accomplished
actor and yet I sense that you feel like
you're not a big deal I didn't want to
bother him right yeah I gotta bring to
the party I sense that's why I worry
about coming here but when you feel like
you're riding a bicycle with bill do you
feel like oh my god I shouldn't be on a
bicycle with Bill Murray because I have
nothing to bring to the party oh you
feel calm it was like it was like after
school I'm mom I'm going riding bikes
with Billy okay when you're gonna be
back you know we don't have to just that
kind of a deal it's an adventure yeah
yeah
[Music]